>>Female Presenter: Author's at Google New
York are very pleased to welcome James Briscione
and Brooke Parkhurst as they introduce their
new cookbook, Just Married and Cooking.
Here we go.
>>James: Yea, here we are.
>>Brooke: [Laughing]
[Applause]
>> Brooke: Thank you guys for coming.
Enjoying your lunch hours with us.
We really appreciate it.
>> James: Yeah, thank you very much.
[clears throat] I actually love this forma,
because I think you guys are helping me prove
a point right now.
Brooke never believes I can pay attention
to her while I'm working on my laptop at the
same time.
I think you guys are going to prove that point.
Help me prove that point.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
I'm James.
My wife Brooke--
>>Brooke: I'm Brooke.
>>James: We're both New Yorkers.
Well, currently New Yorkers at least.
We both grew up down South.
We live here in the city.
Actually just down the street in the village.
I teach full-time at the Institute of Culinary
Education, some of you guys may know the cooking
school up on 23rd street.
And I used to, I was one of the sous chefs
in the private dining room at Restaurant Daniel
before coming to the school to teach.
So I've kind of got a chef and fine dining
sort of background.
And Brooke is a writer—
>>Brooke: I'm a writer.
>>James: and former journalist.
>> Brooke: I used to work for Fox News Channel
and quickly decided that that wasn't going
to be for me.
So I transitioned into my real passion which
were writing and food.
And I published a novel three years ago, Belle
in the Big Apple about a southern girl moving
to New York City.
And then I happened to meet this one and was
able to take my passion for culinary to a
different level because he was patient enough
to work with me.
And from that, we kind of began journey to
write this book which we realize we never
set out to write a book for newlyweds.
It's something that kind of came naturally.
Because like we say in the introduction it's
kind of like the mixed tape.
The foodie mixed tape of our lives.
It was just one song after other of representative
moments.
It was one recipe after the other that we
were cooking for each other in our first year
as both parents and newlyweds.
Things happened a little out of order so we
began our big journey all at once.
So we really had to get in the kitchen because,
you know, we couldn't take out an infant.
We really had to get in there and figure out
how to make amazing meals for each other and
for our tiny family.
>>James: Yeah, so and the book just married
and cooking is really our story.
It's certainly a book for everyone.
It's not explicitly a newlywed cookbook.
I think there's good things in there for every
day for everyone.
It's full of just great recipes.
Things that are really useful but we can point
to almost every recipe in that book and remember
a time when we first started dating five years
ago on up through we pushed send for the last
time to our publishers where we remembered
these meals, preparing them together, enjoying
them together some sort of story.
So they're really part of us and I think the
title of the book comes as much from our story
as it does.
Mark our intended audience.
>> And he gets things kind of fancy or he
enjoys doing things fancy from his background.
I kind of bring him down and say, "honey,
we're not making foie gras every night.
We're not doing country liver pate again.
We're not going to have eggs and bacon every
day for breakfast.
We're going to try to make this a healthy,
easy, elegant cookbook.
He also brings a different level of cooking
to it.
For those of you who are Food Network fans,
if you have time to watch the Food Network,
I don't know.
He was the Food Network two-time Chop Champion.
So he loves crazy ingredients, time constraints,
lights, cameras.
So I have to kind of tame him down for things.
>> James: I enjoy the challenge.
>> Brooke: He enjoys the challenge.
>> James: Like you.
>> Brooke: That's right.
So what we wanted, you know, help you with
today or talk to you about or inspire you
is, you know, with you and your partners,
both of you probably working or with your
roommates, whatever it may be.
You absolutely can get in the kitchen let's
say three, four, five nights a week.
That's what this book was written for, getting
you in the kitchen.
And we think a great place to start is actually
Page 45 in the book and that is our After
Work Apps section.
And it is kind of we love happy hour.
Of course New York has amazing happy hours
especially this time of year.
We love going out for little bites to eat,
great glasses of wine or cocktails.
Not like it add up but sometimes it's just
nice to chill out in your house especially
for those of you who have children.
You kind of have to get back.
You have to get back to the nanny, get back
to the babysitter or just get back to see
your little ones.
So why not just throw your own happy hour
at home?
It's also a great motivator if you're not
quite into the cooking thing yet.
You have this amazing cafeteria.
I would say I would never bring my own lunch.
I don't blame you.
I wouldn't be packing an egg salad sandwich.
I would be enjoying the food truck and everything
else.
But with the apps, it's great because you
can make them the night before.
It kind of coaxes you to come back home and
enjoy a drink and an hors d'oeuvre.
And it kind of gives you something to go on
and actually cook your meal that night.
Because if you come home, you and your partner
are starving.
You want food then.
So if things aren't prepared for you, you're
going to forget.
You're going to scrap your idea of cooking
right, and head out for the takeout.
So this way you got a little bit in your belly.
You're going to be happy, maybe a glass of
wine and then you're going to move on and
maybe think about cooking dinner.
>> James: And so, as you look through those
recipes, they're really really simple.
It's the idea you can make any of these in
30 minutes on a Sunday afternoon or Saturday.
Kind of whatever you had a little bit of time.
And they're all made to keep really well in
the refrigerator.
So whether it's, you know, having a little
happy hour with some friends to your apartment
after you get off work or what Brooke was
saying just knowing that you've got something
ready to eat when you get home so you won't
stop at the deli so you don't stop off somewhere
just grab something while you're going home.
It's something to nibble on while you're waiting.
What we always try to do because we're both
very busy and running.
If I'm at school and Brooke's working and
then with the baby.
We're both kind of running around in different
places.
Really, that end of the day is one of our
few chances to be together.
>> Brooke: And who doesn't love 5 o'clock?
Let's be honest.
It's the time to have a drink.
So you might as well have something delicious
to eat with it, right?
[giggling]
>> James: Absolutely.
For us kind of finding that reason or that
excuse or that motivation to get home and
cook your own meal and start your own meal.
I think that's one really great way to help
yourself get into the mode of doing it.
It's that already have something ready to
eat that's simple and satisfying but enough
to keep you going.
And then, you know, second -- another.
>>Female #1: I was just going to ask -- sorry
to interrupt.
So tell us about when you come home from work.
What should you have in your house right now?
It's early spring and it's 5 o'clock and I
know when I come home from 5 to 7 I can't
think.
>>James: [chuckle]
>>Female #1: So how can we prepare to come
home for the blind spot between 5 and 7?
What would be a good thing to have in the
pantry, have handy so that we don't have to
run to the deli.
That's why I end up.
I end up with an empty refrigerator and that's
where the pizza arrives.
>> James: Perfect.
You took me into the next step.
Really you guys are a great location here.
We spend a lot of time at Chelsea market,
shopping there.
The shops are fantastic.
Another great motivator to go home and cook
something is just go buy something.
Whether it's whatever looks good and beautiful
and seasonal right now.
Certainly asparagus is everywhere and asparagus
is beautiful and they have New Jersey asparagus
at the Manhattan Fruit Exchange.
I was right there yesterday and it's just
perfect.
I think if you, you know, something that you
really love.
One ingredient that you really really like.
Go buy it and just put it in your fridge even
if you don't have a plan for it.
Because then as you start thinking about it
in there as you're working.
Wait a second, asparagus recipes.
let's Google some.
And you know find a great asparagus recipe.
You know, you start thinking about it and
then you're like wait a second, I just spent
five bucks on an asparagus.
I spend another five bucks on a sandwich and
let that asparagus go bad.
I better figure out something to make with
it and get it home.
I feel like I say this every season.
This is my favorite time of the year to cook.
Whenever the seasons change and new stuff
becomes available.
I always get so excited.
>> Brooke: But there's so much available now.
Strawberries, asparagus, little spring onions--
>>James: Peas and carrots.
Turnips are one of my favorite things in spring
that I think a lot of people don't think about
it.
People think of it more as a hearty winter
vegetable.
You get these little beautiful white turnips
radish size and we have those right there
at the Chelsea Market, Manhattan Fruit Exchange
right now.
But it's so much fun, here in New York to
go and visit all of our green markets and
just walk around.
You know, that's where some of the recipes
in our book came from was just from sort of
wandering around the green market, grab a
couple of--
>> Brooke: What was fresh.
What we felt like that day.
But there is, 5 to 7 o'clock period where
you go either way.
So it's great if you have those stalks or
spears of asparagus just waiting for you.
Maybe a half dozen farm eggs and you could
do a great just fried egg on top of blanched
asparagus, you know, a little pecorino on
top, something super, super simple.
>>James: And you gotta have that Ham or bacon
too.
>>Brooke: Ham or Bacon, he puts that in everything.[laughing]
There's no getting around that.
And then also we get asked about the necessary
kitchen equipment.
There really is so much out there.
>> James: Before we move on I just want to
say one other thing on keeping you going or
helping you do it from 5 to 7.
What we often do is, if we're making something,
you know, we make a lot of it.
So if we were going to grill or roast some
chicken breasts or roast the whole chicken,
we might do two whole chickens.
We might do six chicken breasts even though
there's two of us.
Then you have great, good, tasty grilled chicken
just sitting in your fridge and it's so easy
to make a quick salad or to toss it into a
pasta or to--
>>Brooke: Yeah, don't cook for one night.
Cook for three nights.
Cook in larger portions.
And then our next book is about kind of transforming
each night.
And go that you've made the first night.
So you have this kind of one base recipe and
then by adding fresh produce and new spices
it's transformed each day without a lot of
muss and fuss.
My mother did cook seven nights a week my
entire childhood, bless her.
But she was in the kitchen all the time.
And we just don't have that luxury.
>>James: That's another full-time job to do
that.
Don't if you will fool yourself and think
you have to be like they do on TV and whip
something up completely from scratch every
single day.
Kind of embrace that ability to use something,
you know, to utilize,
>>Brooke: Stretch it.
>>James: Make the most of it.
If you're just going for one or two, that
one bunch of asparagus may be more than you're
going to eat in one night.
So blanch all your asparagus.
>>Brooke: Blanch means
>>James: Boiling in salted water to get it
just cooked through and then throw in some
ice water so it stays bright green.
So you might have that with a fried egg and
some ham or bacon one night for dinner.
But then the next day you may chop it up and
toss it with some pasta and feta cheese.
>> Brooke: And Mint and peas makes a great
salad.
>>James: Which is in there somewhere.
>>Brooke: Which is in the book.
>> James: Grilled chicken.
Kind of toss that.
There's always something in our refrigerator.
>> Brooke: That inspires us to create it to,
you know, get in there and cook.
It's never just champagne and mustard.
Ha ha ha. [giggling]
>> James: No.
It's at least orange juice for our daughter,
juice and bananas and yogurt.
>> Brooke: But the next thing also in the
beginning we have a list of kind of can't
miss gotta have kitchen appliances.
I think it's so overwhelming walking into
a Williams Sonoma and the store is so beautiful
and we were cooking there last night.
Yesterday we cooked on the Today Show and
then in the evening we did a signing and demo
at Williams Sonoma.
And I could have left with 5,000 dollars worth
of fun, beautiful kitchen gear.
Aside from having no space and no time in
the apartment, there's really no purpose.
Especially for starting out cooks.
We kind of what a top 5, top what?
Ten list of fun can't miss kind of inexpensive
things, right?
He first taught me about something as simple
as kitchen tongs.
When you are blanching your asparagus, how
are you going to reach in and get them?
All of these things can be intimidating.
Oh, my God I'm going to burn myself.
I don't know how to get it out.
Am I going to pour the whole pot of water
out?
No, you have these simple tools that he's
been using all of what?
Your professional life in kitchens that the
home cook might not think to use that make
your life so much easier.
We love a good set of tongs.
A good microplane zester for grating garlic.
People get intimidated by how to properly
chop up a garlic.
They don't want to do it.
You get a mircoplane zester.
They get intimidated by these 600 dollar knife
sets.
Don't buy a seven piece knife set.
Go out and get one good lightweight Japanese
blade chef's knife or maybe three.
Jamie favors three.
You favor three.
A paring knife, a serrated knife, chef's knife.
That's really all you need in the beginning.
So I think the less you spend in the beginning,
the less likely you are to be let down.
Because it's not like you made this 5,000
dollar investment and things aren't turning
out perfectly.
You made a small investment.
You're learning, you're working and you can
always add on.
The one thing we think you should invest in
is a good Cuisinart.
For a lot of our dips and the after work apps
you're going to need a good Cuisinart.
For a lot of great soups, homemade pestos
that are going to keep throughout the week
to toss with pasta and chicken when you come
home at the end of the day.
That's definitely something worth investing
in.
But there are really few things.
A great wooden cutting board.
Go across to Bowery Trading Company.
What is it called?
>>James: Bowery Kitchen Supply.
>>Brooke: Bowery kitchen supply in Chelsea
market and get a great 50 dollar cutting board
and kind of start from there, right?
>> James: Right.
>> Brooke: Another thing that we say is don't
try to make filet mignon with PB and J skills.
Think about what your skill level is you're
starting off with.
But we have the perfect book for that.
[laughing] But when you're looking at Epicurius
or you're looking online and you get stars
in your eyes and we all want to be Mario Batali
and you pick a really, really difficult recipe.
Maybe it's the second thing you've really
ever tried to cook by yourself.
It's probably not going to turn out to be
fantastic.
So why don't you start out in our book with
the skirt steak with scallion potato cakes.
Skirt steak is inexpensive.
You mess it up.
Okay.
You wasted five dollars.
Say you had bought bone in ribeye for four.
You mess that out, you're out 85 dollars.
Chances are when you mess up the rib eye,
the next thing you're going to do is get takeout.
You mess up the skirt steak, you might go
out and buy a second skirt steak and try it
out.
So the less like I said with all of this the
tools, the food, the less monetarily you invest
in the beginning, the more likely you are
to succeed and kinda continue.
>>James: It all takes practice.
Just like anything.
I think to get good at anything in life, you
got to do it.
So, you know, don't be fooled by TV that makes
it all look so easy.
They wave their hands around, pull something
out from beneath the counter.
Yeah, it's just that easy.
It's not always just that easy.
It's not necessarily that hard.
But it takes a little practice.
It takes some doing.
You know, I was very fortunate kind of throughout
my career to be able to make a lot of mistakes.
Starting out cooking and actually I started
out as a dishwasher when I was 16 years old
and worked my way up through the ranks.
As a teenager cooking, I got to work at a
place where we were always allowed to make
ourselves lunch.
We weren't able to pull out the good steaks
and just grill them all for ourselves.
But to be honest when we had the time we could
make ourselves whatever we wanted to eat.
And I was getting really into cooking and
I was reading a lot and I'd go through books
and see all these things and try to go do
them the next day at work.
I remember the first time I tried to make
risotto, I made it are orzo pasta.
I just didn't know the difference.
I remember the word ended in O. That's pretty
much the shape.
I think this is it.
So my first batch of risotto ever was made
with pasta.
>>Brooke: Not rice.
>>James: And I learned from there, you know.
The chefs were like, "Okay, it tastes good,
but this is no, this is not risotto.
It's not even close.
First of all, it's rice not pasta."
We went on from there.
Making mistakes and expecting mistakes and
knowing it's not always going to be perfect.
But you enjoy it anyway.
And have fun with the process.
That's for one of us the most important things
is just having fun with it and enjoying the
process going through it together.
>> Brooke: And it's great at the end of the
day I think we're all prone, maybe it's your
computer, get in front of the television,
zone out.
Kind of stick one person with chef duty while
the other gets to relax.
Well, you really can relax together in the
kitchen.
Pour yourselves a glass of wine.
Get in there.
Learn together.
Be a little creative.
Use our recipes as kind of the base.
And then, throw in your favorite things.
But try to use that space as something fun
and not a chore.
Which cooking definitely can be or it can
seem like it is.
If you have bad recipes.
But if you have fantastic recipes that are
going to turn out great time and again, ha
ha [laughing] you're going to enjoy it.
>> James: Oops, you have a question?
>>Female #2: So do you have any suggestions
for if you have like a disparity between the
cooking skills.
Like--
>> Brooke: You're really good and your boyfriend's
really bad?
[laughing]
>> Female #2: My husband is really bad.
And I don't want to be in there like, "no,
don't do it like that, you're chopping your
fingers off or your overcooking something."
I don't want to be like the kitchen meister
but at the same time I really don't want to
eat burnt food.
>> James: [laughing]
>>Brooke: That was a good question.
One for him since he is by far better than
I am.
He is the chef.
I am the cook.
>> James: Yeah, we say whenever you're trying
to cook together work together always play
to your strengths—
>>Brooke:Bbut if there are no strengths, what
do you do?
[laughing]
>>James: But if there are no strengths, what
do you do?
You know, I think it's the same thing.
You know, kind of start out small.
Just kind of give him little things to do.
>>Brooke: That clove of garlic in the microplane
zester that you just gone out and bought and
just tell him to grate it.
Or give him a block of cheese in the box grater.
>> James: Now is he really ambitious?
Does he want to do it at all?
>>Brooke: Or is more than you let him?
>> Female #2: Um, Now, I mean he, he wants
to help.
He doesn't want me to be the only person cooking
and doing stuff.
>>Brooke: That's great.
>> Female #2: He's excited about stuff.
He is successful in a couple of things -- however
it takes like four times as long than necessary.
Great on a Saturday but not Tuesday night.
>> Brooke: Not Tuesday night.
>> Female #2: I have to wait until ten O'clock—
>> Brooke: Well, this is I guess when like
prepping, no one likes to hear it but when
prepping ahead.
And this is one of our big pieces of advice
the night before kind of clean your vegetables
or trim your meat or dice things.
In the culinary world "mise en place" getting
everything kind of like restaurant chefs do.
So if you're excited about this Wednesday
dinner you all are going to make say "Honey,
well maybe you should get Tuesday night--
>> James: Tuesday night after we finish dinner,
before we even clean up, let's just go and
have this stuff and we can chop up some of
this stuff for Wednesday.
>>Brooke: Right.
>>James: You can go sit down and relax and
let him take an hour and a half to chop an
onion.
>>Brooke: But that is great.
You don't want to squash—
>> Female #2: It never takes an hour and a
half to cut an onion.
An hour and a half
>> Brooke: We also teach couples cooking at
ICE.
If you want to sign up for those.
Ya'll can come on.
>> James: Bring him in.
Bring him in.
I'll help straighten him out.
>>Brooke: Some of those are fundamentals of
cutting up, properly cutting up an onion.
Properly doing garlic.
Things like that you do need learn once and
learn them well to move on.
>>James: I think learning some base knife
skills is really, really important.
You know, like Brooke said, for we do the
couples classes up at ICE up at the school.
They're a lot of fun.
It's kind of a fun thing to do.
Then you can just sort of stand back and say,
"Yeah, I told you.
I told you that's what you're supposed to
do."
Don't ever do it.
But you know some base knife skills.
That I think once you get it down and learn
how to do it and understand how to use a knife
properly and how to chop things up properly,
it really makes the process more enjoyable
because sometimes that's like the hard tedious
part.
And if it takes you an hour and a half to
chop an onion, you're not going to be really
motivated to do much else.
But when you learn those things and they're
again, it's just something that takes some
practice.
But the skills, the concept of the skills
is really quite simple.
Does anybody else have?
Yeah, please.
>>Female #3: Do you have in your book anything
a child friendly recipes or if a child can
participate?
Are they simple enough for.
>> Brooke: I think a lot of them are.
>>James: They definitely are.
Our daughter is not quite there yet.
She just turned two.
>> Brooke: How old are yours?
>> Female #3: 6 and a half.
>> Brooke: Okay.
So she can.
>> James: You know what?
I think there's.
>> Brooke: Our everyday's dinner's chapter
is just great.
These weeknights we're talking about.
I think everyday dinner is very simple and
general that chapter to look at for these
recipes that you certainly can do with a child.
>> James: The soups and sandwiches.
There's some soups and sandwiches and a few
salads in there that I think are really good.
A lot of them a lot of times are using the
salads like shaved cheese where you just take
the vegetable peeler and you peel the cheese.
I think those are grating cheese and doing
those kinds of things are always good things
for kids.
>> Brooke: Things without heat, hahaha.
[laughting]
>> James: Yeah, I think stirring or mixing
is always good.
So in the breakfast chapter some of the things
like pancakes and muffins—
>>Brooke: and muffins—
>>James: and those kinds of things are really
great healthy muffin recipe in there.
We just had a bout of sickness in our house
and our daughter was a little sick and wasn't
really wanting to eat much.
And I was thinking we need to make, she loves
cookies of course.
As long as we tell her it's a cookie and it's
a little bit sweet and she's convinced.
I was just thinking we needed to make a batch
of muffins and they're healthy and a little
bit sweet and pretty satisfying.
>>Brooke: The granola in here also.
I love my granola recipe, girls and that's
a lot of fun.
Throwing in the different nuts, coconut, dried
fruit, mixing it.
That's a lot of fun you can't go wrong.
You can put more fruit than you need.
More seeds.
>> James: Have you found that your child,
boy or girl?
>>Female #3: Daughter.
>>James: Your daughter, is she more interested
in eating when she gets to help you out with
it?
>> Female #3: She likes to help out just in
general.
She usually does the baking.
>> Brooke: Right.
>>Female #3: She doesn't do skillet or anything
like anything with stove related.
>>James: Right.
>> Female #3: But I'm thinking , I want her
to be more healthy eater at least.
I'm thinking to be involved more in dinner
cooking she might be.
>> James: Definitely.
You know I think-
>>Brooke: The spring pasta we're actually
just talking about the penne with asparagus,
mint, peas, feta has a lot of great greens
in it.
It's very seasonal.
It's perfect for right now.
Let me find the page.
That could be a lot of fun, I think, for a
little one.
>>James: That's a lot of, you could do a lot
of stuff at the stove.
Cook the pasta, cook the peas.
It's all just boiling water.
So you put on one big pot of water.
Throw the pasta in, get it cooked through,
put it in the colander--
>>Brooke: It's page 90 in the book: spring
pasta.
>>James: And then drop your asparagus and
peas in the boiling water.
Scoop them out.
Let them all cool a bit and then put them
in a bowl and you're going to toss it with
some mints and some vinegar and feta cheese
and some scallions . You're just kind of toss
that all together.
You can kind of have all those things separate
and let her add them in mix it up and crumble
up the cheese.
Those are good things for little hands to
do.
Lots of beautiful fresh spring vegetables
that are all really, really great right now.
[pause]
>> Brooke: Do ya'll cook a lot ya'll when
you go home?
He says no; she says yes.
>>James: I don't know how you could working
here.
I don't know I ever would.
It's a very nice setup you guys got here.
>>Brooke: Definitely.
>>James: I'm jealous.
I just want a scooter to ride around.
I could get one push before I bump into a
wall at our apartment, at our office.
>> Female #4: Tell us about how you would
cook for a small family for a special occasion.
Special occasion with adults would be the
big rib eye or whatever but now we have little
kids and not so much time.
How do you suggest planning that day?
Because sometimes to cook for like people
cook for another couple with their little
kid coming over on Saturday.
You need three or four hours to prep.
How would you divide up that three or four
hours?
Would you divide it so everything was ready
when they show up or would you perhaps include
the other family so all of you are working?
What are your thoughts on that?
>>Brooke: I think first and foremost in those
three or four hours, you really should shop
a different day.
Fabulous location, you're right here at Chelsea
market after work one day and get your produce,
your groceries.
Right?
So that's already taken out of that prep time.
Then, yes we actually and the book is divided
into two sections which we haven't even talked
to you about.
There is life as we know it which is a lot
of these everyday type foods.
And the second section is new traditions about
you and your partner and your little family
maybe starting new traditions of your own
not just Christmas or Hanukkah and Thanksgiving,
new ones.
And in several of these menus we talk about
getting your guests involved because that
can be really fun.
We do love doing pizzas at home, homemade
pizzas, you know, whole-wheat flour crusts.
We use a lot of fresh veggies.
Pizza is very fun for the kids.
Stretch and kneed the dough.
We talk about one in the back in our Brussels
sprout salad with a great homemade pesto about
everybody helping, you know, clean the Brussels
sprouts.
>>James: That's one of my favorite menus and
recipe kind of occasion ideas from the second
half of the book.
What do we call it?
>> Brooke: New traditions.
>>James: Right.
It's the menu's called the holiday get away
from the family.
>> Brooke: When you go home.
>> James: Because Christmas time typically
for us it means going back home to where the
parents are.
>>Brooke: Page 299 in the book.
>> James: And usually mom or aunts or uncles
somebody is still going to be hosting the
big holiday dinner.
And when you've been home for three or four
days and you have pretty much all you can
handle of family and your ready to just kind
of get away from them get with friends.
This is like a really fun menu to do with
friends.
Of course very seasonal and prime for November,
December.
And you know, the idea is that you have this
great salad made with Brussels sprouts.
>> Brooke: A sweet potato and brussels sprouts
salad with parmesan pecan pesto.
>>James: It's kind of tedious to pick all
those brussels sprout leaves and it will take
you awhile to do it but we say just have a
batch of cocktails made and when all your
friends get together give everyone a bowl
of brussels sprouts and have them pick the
brussels sprout leaves—
>>Brooke: Make them work for it.
>>James: while you guys catch up and chat
and sip your cocktails so then you're ready
to go.
It depends on what you're making.
>> Brooke: The key is that we teach in our
classes though you want to get them involved
but don't actually think they want to make
it from start to finish with you.
Like, when you have this pizza party.
Don't actually give them a cup of water, flour
and to make the dough.
You want to have a lot of it prepped ahead.
It's just going to be easier and more enjoyable
for everyone.
So to answer Kate's question directly what
would we say?
Be well prepared.
>>James: Yeah, be well prepared.
One of the things we always teach in our cooking
classes up at ICE is a lot of times it's nice
in the menus.
We always do one seafood and one meat whether
it be pork or chicken or beef or whatever
as part of a dinner party menu.
One of the great tricks is being in New York
City -- at least us -- if you cook fish in
your apartment, you're going to know for awhile.
Most people in your hall are going to know
you cooked some fish.
That smell can just kind of hang for awhile.
So a great trick for doing, you know, fish
for dinner party or having friends over is
just actually just sear the fish on one side.
Get it really nice brown in the pan and then
take it out and put it onto baking pan other
side completly raw.
And then, you can light some candles, open
the windows, turn on a fan and clear out the
apartment.
Then when you're ready to actually have your
dinner when you're ready to serve all you
have to do is throw that tray of fish into
the oven.
Takes about five minutes if the oven is at
425 degrees.
The fish will be cooked through perfectly.
It will have that perfect it won't look like
sad baked fish.
I would say cafeteria food, but you guys don't
have sad cafeteria food here.
It would look like a beautiful, roasted piece
of fish but you're not going to deal with
the smell, the oil splatter and all of that
mess.
Pre-cooking thing is such a great investigate
thing to do.
>> Brooke: That's a chef's trick that we do
in the restaurant.
>>James: That's what most restaurants do in
the reality of it.
When you think about when you go to a restaurant
sit down and order a bowl of risotto and in
eight minutes, the bowl of risotto is at your
table.
Start to finish that's a 35 minute process.
So the risotto is 75 percent cooked—
>>Brooke:In the morning
>>James: In the morning, miday and then it's
cooled down and held in the refrigerator and
then when you order it they just heat up a
pot and . And there's nothing wrong with that
at all.
We kind of always have this romantic image
>>Brooke: Fresh.
>>James: of all these things being made from
scratch.
>>Brooke: In the moment.
>> James: But pre-cooking things having things
prepared.
Like we said, having things ready in your
fridge is really a wonderful way to go about
it.
>>Brooke: Another great thing—
>James: And it's the reality I think for all
of us.
Kind of the way we live our lives and the
time constraints we have for cooking and working
these days.
>> I think it's also really fun when you have
people over and we think it's really easy
to have bottles of wine.
Girls love wine.
We love to get with the girls, eat cheese,
crackers, drink wine.
It's great.
In the book we have several chapters dedicated
to cocktails, house drinks.
And if you're on a budget, it actually works
out to be more economical to make great house
cocktails if you think about a person's going
to have, each guest is going to have two or
three glasses apiece, think of how many bottles
of wine you're going to go through.
As opposed to you buy one nice bottle of what
would be liquor and you jazz it up with some
fresh juices.
We like our rosemary fresh lemonade infused
with rosemary and vodka.
All of that is so much more inexpensive and
you also get these big points for being a
very kind of inventive creative hostess when
all you're doing is just following our book.
[laughing]It's a great touch.
It's personal to make those drinks and have
those ready instead of just wine.
And like I said, it's easier on the budget
also.
>> Female #5: Hi guys.
>>James: Hey.
>>Female #5: So sometimes cooking in New York
is really uninspiring not just because of
the budget or the expensive food but because
your space itself is so uninspiring.
It's small or ugly or cramped or your sharing
it with a roommate--
>>Brooke: Bad ventilation.
>>Female #5: All those things.
So I'm wondering if you have tips about how
to make the space itself more appealing so
you want to get on in there.
So whether it be tips on storage, tips on
making it look prettier, keeping it clean.
Sometimes I don't want to go in the kitchen
because I don't want to be in there.
I don't want to spend two hours in that room.
Sometimes being in the kitchen is because
it's not fun.
>> Brooke: First of all, removing clutter
from the counters, having nice clear clean
counters.
Think, are you actually using that toaster
oven?
Do you actually use the microwave that much?
Are you actually using the toaster?
Different little things that perhaps can be
moved away so you have this clear counter
space.
What else honey?
Mr. Organization in the kitchen.
>>James: Yeah, I'm the one--
>> You are.
>> James: Usually in charge of that typically.
I mean, it is really challenging i think in
New York.
Counter space is almost always at a premium.
So you do your best to maximize it.
We have two different size cutting boards
we use depending on what's going on really
what we're working on.
Which cutting board you're going to pull out.
You know, keeping just things really -- I
mean, just keep things organized.
>> Female #5: I guess do you guys turn on
music when you're in the kitchen?
Do you decorate?
I mean, the last place I think of you know
when I'm at IKEA or target is decorations
for the kitchen.
But do you guys have photo frames--
>> Brooke: Well, one great thing actually
for organization is we have what is it called?
A knife.
>>James: The magnetic knife strip.
>>Brooke: Knife strip
>>James: So the knifes hang up on the wall.
>> Brook: So that's one less thing also on
your counter.
You have the strip up there.
The knives are arranged nicely.
The Container Store we do love.
We do have a really big kind of pantry so
we're lucky for that.
>> James: Yeah.
We have, you know, just having things accessible
and not having to dig through cabinets.
Which may seem goes against what we just said.
But actually in the book here in the very
beginning there is a list of all the tools
you should have and how to use them.
And they're organized by where you should
store them.
There's things that should be in the drawer,
you have one drawer that you pull out that
has your peeler and whatever else in it.
And then, we always keep a little crock or
container right next to the stove that has
mixing tools: a whisk and a spatula and the
spoons, metal spoon and a wooden spoon and
a little scooper.
>>Brooke: Your tongs.
>> James: For scooping things out of the stove.
So those things you would tend to use at the
stove are there.
And I think sort of I think that's actually
a really good guide.
We spent a good bit of time--
>>Brooke: It begins on page can have 5, where
to keep things.
>> James: Putting that together.
But having the specific sort of stove tools.
Keep them by the stove.
Keep the things by the drawer.
Keep the mixing bowls together in one cabinet.
If you can just dedicate a few spaces to that.
And you know don't keep a drawer full of takeout,
because you know you're going to get fresh
takeout menus every single day at your apartment
anyway.
>> Brooke: Dedicate that drawer to new kitchen
tools.
>> James: That's right.
>> Brooke: We love music.
I love a glass of wine when I cook, um, sometime.
>> James: We're actually very fortunate too.
We have a kitchen that just has little island
that looks out over our living room.
>> Brooke: Otherwise our daughter would never
see us if our kitchen was in a different part
of the apartment or if it were closed off,
she would never see us.
Luckily we do have an open kitchen to the
living room.
>> James: We watch her scribble on the pillows
and chalk like she was just doing this morning**
>>Brooke: Morning.
>>James: before we left.
[pause]
>>Female: #6: Hi.
>>Brooke: Hi.
>>Female #6: The thing that I always have
trouble with is grocery shopping.
Like I'll go out Sunday and be like Oh yeah,
these veggies this looks great.
And then I'll come home on a Monday night
and I don't know how to cook this.
I don't know how to make this and I'll realize
I need ten other ingredients I didn't actually
buy.
So do you guys plan out a menu every week?
Do you find yourself running out?
>> Brooke: We keep staples in the pantry which
is also in the beginning of the book with
the tools.
Things you should have all the time.
Then you can just work from and throw in fresh
things in addition to that.
So we begin with a well-stocked pantry.
Which is of course easy to say, but it makes
a lot of sense to go ahead.
Always have not just the flour and the sugar
but anchovies for one of our pasta sauces.
To always have the chicken broth.
To have those things.
Have a very basic spice cabinet.
And then what else honey?
>>James: Yeah, and you know the other thing
I think don't feel so bound to a recipe.
You know.
>> Brooke: Easy for him to say.
Easy for a Chop Champion to say.Just whips
it up at the last minute.
I'm more like you.
I like to follow a recipe.
>>James: If you have one or two ingredients,
doesn't mean you can't make it.
If you don't have a teaspoon of that spice,
you can go without it.
>>Brooke: Right.
>>James: It will be okay.
You can kind of, you know, work around those
things.
But we definitely do plan.
I mean, I actually have a list in my back,
I'm going to Chelsea market as soon as we
finish here.
I have a list in my back pocket of things
kind of think about what we want to make or
what we're going to make.
And make out a list.
But --
>>Brooke: And menu planning is really great.
You can think and plan out just three meals
or maybe start with two.
Do not be overly ambitious because you might
go out with your girlfriends or husband or
boyfriend or what else.
But make sure you have two and make sure you
get all the ingredients for those two.
And that can be your meal planning.
And then you can plan on two nights of leftovers.
That's already four nights covered and do
cook that on Sunday.
That will last you to Wednesday.
Meal planning, it sounds like kind of what
a suburban housewife would do.
Totally unnecessary and way too organized
but it's great to do.
It's already in your head when you're at work
or walking home or getting on the subway.
What am I going to eat?
This is all so overwhelming.
Well, you know because you decided on Sunday
and you're taken care of until Friday.
And what we were talking about with Kate,
basically whatever you cook for yourself is
going to be more healthful than almost anything
you get in a restaurant or takeout.
You know exactly what's going into it.
Whether you're watching your figure or just
trying to be healthy.
It's great to know everything that's going
into your food.
Or you can take things out our of recipes.
You don't want so much cheese or sour cream
that he added.
You can take it out and be fine with it.
We love our takeout also, but once you get
used to eating very healthfully at home and
then you have this takeout food or restaurant
food, it's "wow, it's so salty, wow, it's
so sweet or wow, it's so heavy."
>> James: And there's also substitutes.
When you get that great Thai recipe and it
calls for fish sauce.
You're not going to buy a whole bottle of
fish sauce just to make one thing--
>>Brooke: Soy sauce.
>>James: one time.
Soy sauce is a good substitute.
You pull out the little packets that you saved
up from your sushi takeout that you saved
up for the last three months.
>> Brooke: Also by the way for these questions
things like this we have a website by the
same name.
Honestly, we always answer questions.
So for any of you guys feel free to write
us and ask questions like about "I don't have
fish sauce, what can I do Jamie?"
[laughing] You can write us and we'd love
to answer all your questions.
>>Female Presenter: Any other questions?
I think that would be it.
Thank you so much for your time, we really
appreciate it.
>>James: Great, well thank you guys.
>>Brooke: Thank you guys for coming.
[Applause]